style qui a eu des propos assez
controversé sur la procréation
médicalement assistée élus de l'oise
elle est connue pour son opposition à
l'ouverture de la pma aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes célibataires
elle avait ainsi comparé la souffrance
des femmes en manque d'enfants à celles
de drogués
des propos qui avaient fait beaucoup
réagir notamment au sein de la
république en marche et conduit le
mouvement envisager son exclusion
finalement elle sera auditionné avant
qu'une décision soit prise alors une
députée peut-elle tout dire même si
c'est en contradiction avec la ligne de
son parler de son parti on va en parler
mais je vous propose d'abord d'écouter
gabriela talent qui était donc ce matin
sur rtl
on l'écouté - d'une manière générale je
suis pas favorable à ce qu'on exclue sur
la base d'opinions ce soit il ya des
déclarations qui tombent sous le coup de
la loi et dans ce cas-là ça justifie un
fait juridique s'est justifié une
exclusion soyez un fait politique voter
contre un budget voté contre un texte
important et ça juste ici une exclusion
si on se met à exclure sur la base de
déclarations je sais pas on s'arrête sur
argumenté finalement c'était un parti
godillot alors la micra/march ses
parents il y avait quand même quelque
chose c'est que macro en vais considérer
que tous les députés nous s engager et
leur donner en quelque sorte un mandat
impératif ce qui ne correspondait pas du
tout à la pratique de la cinquième
niveau texte est pas il s'est engagé
parce que parce qu'il ya le texte
évoquait la plateforme ios 4 former les
gens devaient s'engager dans le très
vaste renouvellement avec beaucoup de
gens qui débarquent je pouvais être
clair et qui ne connaissait pas trop la
politique ni des arcanes de la politique
et puis dans l'impréparation naturel
parce que 300 nouveaux députés bas c'est
évidemment 300 personnalités career
chacune parfois avec leurs opinions qui
sont des marcheurs de dernière minute
parfois et donc ça se traduit par ses
déclarations révélant personnellement
vous seriez pour contre une sanction vis
à vis de cette je trouve ces propos
extrêmement déplacée elle a le droit
d'avoir des opinions
quand elle considère que des femmes qui
souhaitent des enfants sont des drogués
je trouve ça extrêmement déplacé je
trouve ça pas humainement acceptable
donc j'ai pas spontanément beaucoup
d'affection pour certains le déclare
dire
c'est la question même choc de se
demander si elle a le droit de le dire
on est dans un pays de liberté
d'expression liberté d'expression ces
libertés d'offenser si on ne tolère que
les idées qui vont dans le sens on ne
tolère absolument rien donc bien sûr
qu'elle a le droit de s'exprimer de dire
des idées que je ne partage en rien du
tout mais exclure pour des offenses pour
des mots ça s'appelle censure et ça
s'appelle disgracié c'est encore une
fois très monarchique que je trouve que
la responsabilité lui incombe en se
disant je suis dans un parti
les idées ne correspondent en rien à mes
convictions que j'ai dit fort qu'elle
soit responsable et qu'elle se retire
d'elle même c'est très déresponsabiliser
de sa part de ne pas se retirer elle
même mais vouloir enfin qu'un parti
décide d'exclure pour préjudice oui pour
des faits que monsieur attal l'a dit oui
pour des offenses et pour des mots
jamais dans un pays de liberté
d'expression
marie visot votre avis alors à une toute
petite nuance près bien sûr qu'elle a le
droit d'exprimer ses convictions même si
ce ne sont pas celles de son parti c'est
une députée elle sait que le sujet ce
sujet est explosif dans la société
elle doit quand même faire attention aux
mots qu'ils utilisent
il ya eu des mots assez violent et parle
pas une seule fois par erreur à la
récidive et elle elle a refait des
maladresses et un moment où on se
demande si c'est vraiment des
maladresses c'est presque une question
de sémantique est ce que
dams est député elle aurait pas pu dire
il faudrait s'interroger sur on pourrait
débattre de en fait alors ai pas dit
autre chose que ce qu'elle a dit mais ça
aurait tout changé sur le fond oui mais
donc chez les mots qui font mal selon
elle veut convoquer mais alors dans ce
cas pourquoi est-ce qu'elle va à la
république au marché voilà en gros c'est
ça exactement même la position des deux
en mars se sent qu'elle a évolué sur le
sujet qu'au départ oui elle et qu'elle a
changé d'avis elle a changé d'avis au vu
des débats qui évoque les mois la
mission parlementaire je n'y crois pas
parce qu'elle n'aurait pas ses mots avec
cette dureté moi ce manque d'humanité je
trouve si elle avait voulu version de
s'exprimer au poignet non non non non
non non non c'est pas une façon c'est
enfin pardon moi je considère qu' on
pourrait on joue pas responsable la
république en marche dans le monde mac
mais on pourrait effectivement sur ces
termes la considérer qu'elle a franchi
une ligne et qu'elle ne correspond pas
du tout à la plateforme politique du
minimal censuré non ce n'est pas censuré
c'est vous ne dites pas les idées qui
concorde avec les notes donc on vous
exclamer ses passes en six mois elle
peut toujours regretter l'une sur une
séparation très très tyrannique hommes
comme c'est pas tyrannique
si vous avez été élu sur une plateforme
vous n'êtes plus en phase avec les idées
on en tire les conclusions c'est tout
aussi simple que ça saharien de
tyrannique
non mais vous ne dites pas exactement
les mots qu'on aimerait que vous ne fait
pas une question de mots c'est que ce
parti l'a fait preuve d'une certaine
ouverture elle est contre cette
ouverture c'est tolérable
l emploi en plus des mots que je trouve
vexatoires déplacer et peu humain là
tout à coup il me semble qu'elle prend
une tangente mêlée ccl si vous voulez
qu'est en train de sortir du jeu
oui mais elle de sortir je vois pas
pourquoi on
l'un des magasins et d'ailleurs y avoir
une décision prise aujourd'hui
finalement on a l'impression que c'est
embêtant parce que la liberté sûr
d'avoir scellé mais on a tu as raison
sur ce point à l'espagne on en repart
ensuite tous ensemble non mais je crois
que vous vous posez le débat je suis
tout à fait d'accord c'est à dire que
c'est pas tant le fait qu'elle puisse
exprimer une opinion divergente
on va dire de la majorité de son parti
qui pose problème c'est la manière dont
elle le fait et je crois
qu'effectivement les mots qu'elle
utilise sont extrêmement violents
vis-à-vis des gens qu'elle vise comparée
des femmes qui soient en désir d'enfant
à des drogués dire par ailleurs que si
on adoptait la pma tout le monde irait
dans des écoles coraniques
on est content actualiser la voilà
l'idée étant que la démo alors pour
terminer juste je pense que oui a droit
à laufon souilhe à un droit au blasphème
dont acte je suis d'accord avec
maintenant il ya quelque chose de
particulier je trouve qu'on est dans un
contexte singulier c'est à dire qu'on y
est on est dans une situation politique
où ce gouvernement la république en
marche un certain nombre de personnes
sont confrontés à une violence verbale
incroyable où se dit à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi sur les réseaux sociaux
et parfois sur des plateaux de
télévision
si l'un des représentant l'une des
représentantes de la république de
surcroît du parti au pouvoir n'a pas
l'intelligence d'avoir des propos qu'on
m'a qualifié de mesuré même pour
exprimer son désaccord
je pense que ça pose un léger problème
politique alors après c'était la
république en marche de voir ce qu'il
veut le faire voilà elle a fait réagir à
pour poursuivre un peu on l'a dit
mathieu vous avez fait une interview de
l'avocat eric dupond moretti dans l'obs
il dit tout un tas de choses que je vous
recommande de lire très intéressante
il dénonce une société devenue selon lui
hyper moralisatrice hyper hygiéniste
hypertransport exactement avec aussi une
édulcoration des mots une féminisation
des mots il ne faut pas de mots trop
violent et je suis d'accord avec vous le
vocable le vocable les dunes
dancing oui mais il faut tout atténuer
donc les aveugles sont des personnes à
il est l'une des malvoyants et les
personnes handicapées à mobilité réduite
et on va vers une mesure une
moralisation du vocabulaire mais la
liberté d'expression vraiment dans son
principe si on commence à dire on ne
tolère que des mots mesurés
on n'est vraiment pas dans un pays de
liberté d'expression liberté
d'expression c'est je suis pas d'accord
je suis pas d'accord un pays
démocratique c'est un pays on s'accepte
c'est un pays vont se tolèrent c'est un
pays ont fait preuve de bienveillance et
les mots de cette dame ne sont pas des
mots bienveillants et à partir de là à
partir de là elle a tout à fait le droit
de s'exprimer sur la place publique
je ne démens pas ça du tout mais à
partir de ce moment là dans un parti
politique qui avait dirigé la
bienveillance comme une règle du jeu sur
un débat où elle est en contradiction
totale avec ce parti politique je n'y
vois nulle ostracisme si vous voulez
personnel nul édulcoration qu'on lui
imposerait mais juste rester dans la
ligne politique de son parti et ça c'est
un paradoxe inouïe on vous écrit mais
restez dans votre lit non ça c'est bon
mais non elle est là le roi canucks elle
a le droit à cette dame a le droit
d'avoir des convictions sur ces
nouvelles formes de maternité non mais
elle a le droit au sein de son parti de
les avoir simplement le vocabulaire
qu'ils utilisent
je le trouve très dévastateur est
absolument pas en phase avec les valeurs
que le parti de la rue de gand marche
souhaite mme ouellet c'est ça moi je
suis d'accord simplement elle a le droit
de les dire et on doit les tolérer on
doit tolérer les mots intolérable c'est
ça la liberté non en démocratie ou moins
toléré dans un parti politique un parti
politique les lignes politiques
à partir du moment où vous faites des
pas de côté messahel alors justement
saisir je suis pas dans un parti qui
tolèrent mémo qui teulère mes idées dont
je me retire
melix mais elle le fait pas c'est ça le
problème alors que le parti en revanche
l'exclu d'emblée c'est une toute autre
démarche et c'est beaucoup plus les
questions qu'on se pose là pour être
tout à fait honnête on se les est posée
à l'ops quand il s'est agi de faire
cette interview et puis de maître eric
dupond moretti
parce que la question ne font qu'y est
posée c'est peut-on tout dire at on le
droit de tout dire
c'est une question de fond c'est une
question qui occupe beaucoup de nos
contemporains en ce moment on a posé la
question d'ailleurs un eric dupond
moretti qui est plutôt partisan de tout
dire ou de dire beaucoup de choses
simplement elle dit il existe aussi des
abuseurs liberté je suis pour la liberté
mais il faut savoir aussi qu'il existe
aussi des abuseurs de liberté après tout
problème est alors retombée le flore
seulement voilà le beaucoup de
philosophes ont placé le curseur c'est
un outil je trouve assez percutant entre
quand est ce qu'on ne doit arrêter cette
liberté d'expression ou est-ce que le
curseur entre la différence et entre
l'auf ans des mots intolérable et le
préjudice
quand il ya préjudice et je pense que
les avocats vont dans ce sens bien sûr
que ça devient intolérable et consent et
qu'on est con punis mais tant qu'on est
dans l'offensive dans les mots on ne
peut pas vous avez raison du point de
vue de l'ensemble des gens et je pense
que la loi est un curseur c'est à dire
qu'il ya un certain nombre de propos
quand ils deviennent injurieux raciste
ou antisémite donc bien évidemment on ne
peut pas les prononcer là après on est
dans un contexte très politique d'un
député donc il ya aussi toute la phase
politique qui qui qui qui est discutable
alors ce discussion est très intéressant
le dernier mot adam internautes
c'était la question vous été posée assis
êtes vous pour ou contre l'exclusion de
la députée allier style du groupe
la république en marche et bien vous
êtes 52% à être contre cette possible
exclusion nicole nous dit on ne veut
voir qu'une tête à la république en
marche et l'on dit elle devrait partir
d'elle-même donc elle vous rejoins plus
tôt et brownie toan y est ils semblent
se mettre elle même hors jeu trois
points de suspension gros gâteau il est
formidable
ça sera le mot de la fin julia de funès
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et pour
prolonger les débats
vous le savez le figaro magazine
organise son grand débat vous allez voir
la bande annonce vous pouvez participer
il ya une adresse mail tout ce qu'il
faut